[Applaudissements]
c'est ça votre vie je sais pas le talent
toujours à contre sens ça va être encore
là c'est le printemps il fait beau vous
avez bien c'est vrai que c'est votre
dernière avant dernière chronique à ça
me fait un nom à la con pénultième
antépénultième sommes d'accord donc ça
veut dire qu'il reste trois en comptant
celles regza pas là vous auriez fait une
belle carrière
les prochaines courses à ben je sais pas
c'est à vous de me dire ah bah non c'est
à vous de me dire ah bah écoutez moi je
suis partant si c'est cela veut dire ça
fait quoi
vous voyez une augmentation du virement
quoi bon qu'à une augmentation à nibali
ban ou la non moins une augmentation ou
pas oui
écoute je te dis oui une petite
augmentation bonbons on est sûr que tu
seras pas la cellule votre compte vos
vacances franchement la crise et où je
ne peux pas mais je te le dis on m'a dit
que vous étiez vous étiez bien quand
même vous avez dit que vous n'êtes pas
mal tu la fermes a presque en tout 1
mondiale via cydia cinquième fois tu
m'appeler
vous n'aimez pas beaucoup les 22
meilleurs jeux
[Applaudissements]
lambotte chanter ma dose et je prends le
jeune j'avais prévu de vous reconduire
l'année prochaine
tous les jolis bijoux comme tous les
génies
c'est tous les jeudis d'accord on
bascule au possible ont pas ce que je
serais quand même le vendredi avec la
démission vendredi un projet d'accord
tous les jeunes y a donc ça veut dire
que je pourrais arriver à l'heure pour
manger tout cru à tous les jeudis ou en
moyenne un petit restaurant droite
ristournes ne veulent pas je suis ric et
rac en ce moment bon on verra ça allez
vous vous avez compris après ces
tractations que vous avez très peu de
chances de le revoir
vous faites quoi d'ailleurs de vacances
cet été
parce que je propose un peu de temps
elle nous est pas ce que tu ressens
comme ça de faire tout drôle à seller de
la feta sa cote solidarité pmp avec un
invité spécial
il est à côté de moi c'est tout le site
tunisien c'est le tout c'est de futurs
50 secondes et a été pompé spécial baba
on commence avec bayti famille qui
visiblement reçu la même dose de vaccin
quand je rêve de toi
et vous cherchiez à principales qualités
de cyril hanouna le natel bien sûr la
suisse était à l'honneur
regardez ils sont arrivés troisièmes
avec cette chanson sa chanson tout
l'univers
c'était pas mal
heureusement que sap a gagné cette merde
rien à dire baba connaît par coeur ou
six équipes
merci grosse [ __ ] la grosse [ __ ] mais
quand cyril hanouna se transforme en
fabio salsa cévennes ce combat se prend
pour un habitué du métropolis ça plaît
pas forcément aux invités on a avec nous
martin blachier chez blachier on avec
tous laurent alexandre
samassa
mais sans pas content le roi du paf
quand tu fais que l'éthique ça fait mal
qui bat à manger du saucisson en gagnant
ceux ci sont secs berbère amsellem
[Musique]
quelques piques à son montant était de
faire le sois fort les interviews les
médecins en majorité ce sont vaccinés
d'entrée de jeu et après il a fallu
discuter avec les infirmières et avec
les aides soignants mais mais mais mais
je peux vous dire que ça c'est c'est
absolument tout le monde était descendu
pour pour venir matériaux et sur mes
fameux signalement l ouverture de ces
enquêtes et on finit avec la punchline
la semaine ce n'est pas mort bien sûr 2%
de texans vacciner j'ai regardé les
chiffres aussi ce matin un lapin
[Rires]
j'te jure t un tat tu t'étais qui toi je
te remets ta gueule qu'est ce qu'un
autre qui arrive ou là j'ai du dos
session alors on a testé le niveau de
générosité des chroniqueurs c'est
horrible quoi chasser mais si vous avez
besoin de quelqu'un autour de cette
table ou qu'ils nous regardent et la
maison ne me demandez pas alors ça c'est
énorme c'est vrai alors c'est une
catastrophe mais me voue un vous avez
pas voulu augmenter on les murs
oui on a testé générosité des
chroniqueurs avec une personne de
l'équipe qui a coutume de ce très
souvent perdre sa carte bleue cette
personne c'est sur un soin feu à dorer
alors du coup on s'est servi de ces
tests pour les tester un peu tous et
vous allez voir qu'ils ont pas tous
forcément le coeur soit je sens que ça
avait très peur je suis un crevard
je suis dans la merde pourquoi je sais
vous aimez macarthur encore way
s'ajoutent à quelque chose et me voilà
retrouvera macadam soit 50 60 euros
du cinéma non non non non
je vais voir de se voir ta de la monnaie
sur toi j'en conclus jamais d'argent
[ __ ] ça les 50 on regarde la copie de
ce qu'elle a dit elle a dit j'appelle
mon fils est clair amen c'est mignon tu
vois
non mais c'est le geste je vais jetons
comme j'ai pas ça va
fabio les titres sur toi
[Musique]
un beau projet
ballack avoir l'interdiction des doigts
c'est en voiture
quant au juge ahmed oz j'avais de
l'oseille ça se saurait
on va te faire [ __ ] à chanu 2000 ans
va te faire [ __ ] des cv il a jamais
d'argent mais parce que je vais te dire
que tu es devenue une fan d'argent
dégoûte
surfer de 50 balles mais t'as pas
aujourd'hui on en as hausse et on n'a
pas besoin d'argent arrête entrevoir un
peu d'argent mais c'est mieux qu'un
d'argent bravo à une réussite comme ça
valérie bénard l avantage c'est qu'il
vous prêtent de l'argent après s'en
souvient plus beau à regarder
[Rires]
il convient de préciser que il a cherché
pendant une demi-heure face aux horaires
s'était barré elle avait la chercher
dans toute la ville et le jury reconnaît
israël comme ça j'ai dit [ __ ] épopée
c'est moi on n'est pas ce que je vous
décris terre on est en sortie du tulle
au doigt sinon je vais passer sur les 52
à les autres ça et oui donc celle on a
vu qu'on pouvait compter sur vous et
vous savez moi je suis l'indiquent je
sais tout je vois tout je dénonce tout
et j'ai prévu de cafarder pourquoi parce
que guillaume genton n'a pas du tout été
sympa avec un d un de ses camarades
autour de la terre je te comprends tout
à fait non mais là ça a été très violent
ah c'est le retour d'une séquence au
titre le plus court du monde le jeu qui
va partir en sucette sur la tête de
tackle fait dès maintenant
oui dès maintenant c'est à dire que oui
c'est à quoi d'autres après mais je suis
prêt après si je m'occupe de votre cas
après s'être essayée lui le sentier
ça va partir en sucette sur la tête des
tatas quand tu m'envoies d'entre elles
c'est mon fils mais pourriture
j'étais truc la fia lesquelles ce
week-end normand
le délai qu'elle n'en jetons continent
ces kits et benjamins
à peine ses choix
et appelle souvent week-end
guillaume salle en plus t'es bourré de
défauts
[Applaudissements]
vous la paix tous les soirs et puis même
pas son numéro de téléphone c'est pas
vrai m'appelle team et s'habitue crois
que j'étais moins il n'est pas bien et
pas bien avec cagliari ou pas je pose de
téléphone lesparre et c'est très très
beau les racines noires comme ça déjà
tant elle était un marron glacé alors et
beaucoup de choses mais gardons le
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
contact que je donne merci paris on sent
pas mon chéri alex beh oui oui bonjour
de paris de djerba du pakistan oui eh
bien il ya une région qui vous tient par
qui tuent leurs particulièrement à coeur
et cette région elle est plus connue sur
le nom de taxe à manger du sauciflard je
m'éloigne ainsi vous voulez un geste
voulait plus de moi je t'adore ça me
fait beaucoup de peine et frère j'ai
l'impression d'avoir une charcuterie
avec moi ma mère c'est quoi c'est un
chewing gum au tsunami
la série des passionnés par une région
le texas si je vous dis là corner beef
corner
regardez c'est baba texas ranger tout
comprendre je me rappelle de sang
la s'initie américaine telle agence des
maladies américaine sur son site
internet
chouette le masque est obligé religieux
ou au tir elle dit quoi lasser les six
records boeuf qu'on a des scores
apparaissent à bois bobigny c'est bon
des mesures sanitaires mois on n'a
d'impact sur l'épidémie finalement je
sais que walker il est vacciné le
portugal par exemple quand on
s'intéresse aux personnes vulnérables
celles qui meurent nicoby de ses escales
et la cbi scicolone pif petit choix
[Musique]
non mais regardez la réalité et au lej
moi mais vous non ça va changer parfois
que dit la sig aussi la corde et au nom
n'est pas chez ta mère
le texas est ce que voulait pas que j'en
parle c'est le deuxième état le plus
peuplé bédié n'ont pas et alors on peut
parler du texas oui j'adore le groupe
alors je vous rends la donne l'exemple
du texas emploi alors leur parti au
texas s'y associe la courbe officielle
du gouvernement qui a mis tout le monde
nous parle d'un danger jimmy jimmy de
las vegas
est-ce que vous avez un petit peppers
board pour un petit c'est un petit
schéma rapidement là c'est le texas
vous laissez le texas c'est la colère
gronde début alors on part alors à ces
sites un mode et vous allez en quelques
sortes les bosses féminines en gros ce
qui se passe avec la vaccination c'est
votre journal à tout pousse on vous
donne un petit message et l arn messager
qui me
[Applaudissements]